There was once a boy whose name was Aladdin.
One day, a few years after his father died, a man came to visit him and his mother.
"I am the boy's uncle," the man said,...
..."so I will help him."
He took Aladdin to the beautiful garden.
"I can make you rich," the man said to Aladdin,...
..."but you must do as I say."
In one part of the garden, there was a large stone.
"Very well, Uncle," Aladdin said.
He thought the man was his uncle, but the man was not.
He was a wicked magician who needed Aladdin's help.
"Cover yourself with your robe," he said,...
..."then lift the stone."
"There are steps under it."
"At the bottom of the steps, you will see many rooms."
"In one of the rooms, you will find a lamp,"...
..."bring it to me."
"Wear this ring," he said,...
..."it will keep you from harm."
Aladdin climbed down the steps and walked through the rooms.
Soon, he found the lamp.
The man was waiting for him.
"Give me the lamp," he said.
Aladdin argued with the man.
"I will not give you the lamp until I am out of this hole," he said.
The man became very angry.
"Then, you will never get out of the hole," he said.
He pushed the stone over the hole and returned to Africa.
Aladdin tried to push the stone out of the way, but he could not.
For three days, Aladdin was stuck in the hole.
On the third day, he looked at the ring on his finger.
"My uncle said, 'This will keep you from harm,'" he thought.
He turned it on his finger.
Immediately, a genie stood in front of him.